And Spacey.
I love this combination
of Siphon and spacey.
This is one of my favorite combinations
for machine learning. All right.
Hello world.
It's Saroj and welcome to my live stream
on natural language processing in.
See now I know a lot of you might be
thinking why see write python works well
enough.
It's a great introductory language to
bring a lot of people into the field,
but there is a problem.
And let me tell you what that problem is.
The problem is that sometimes we want
really fast implementations of machine
learning algorithms.
We want machine learning algorithms that
are going to work very, very well, very,
very fast. And, uh, you know,
I'm talking about health care,
I'm talking about life
or death situations.
I'm talking about times when milliseconds
matter for both inference and for
training.
So what see allows us to do as a language
is to manually allocate memory and
manually deallocate memory.
So what's happening in python and the
python runtime environment is a process
called garbage collection. Okay. And a
lot of you might be familiar with this,
but garbage collection is a runtime
process that automatically looks for,
um, that looks for objects in memory
that have not been deallocated.
And if, if it, if it, depending on the
type of interpreter we're using it,
if it feels like it's time
to deallocate that object,
it will deallocate it for us.
Now this is great because we don't want
to have to spend our time dealing with
memory, right? Allocating
objects, d allocating them.
We just want to worry
about the algorithms.
Okay?
So, uh, that's why we use python,
but sometimes it's necessary.
So in this livestream,
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
first demo how [inaudible] works.
[inaudible] is by the way, is it's a
bunch of sea extensions for python.
So we could literally write
c code inside of Python.
And I want you to do this
with me in a Google colab.
So go to colab.research.google.com
and once we've done that,
we will, uh, we'll first coat
out a python implementation,
then we'll do a site on implementation.
We'll benchmark both of them.
And then we're going to use it
for natural language processing,
specifically using a
library called spacey.
And then after that we're going to demo
it for a little bit more deep learning
after that. All right, so we've got a
lot of things to do in this live stream.
Um, I will marry you
Conrad. Thank you very much.
I will marry all of you because you guys
matter to me a lot, like a lot. So, okay,
so let's get into this. I want you to
do this with me in the browser. Yes,
we can code, see inside
of the browser. Okay.
I'm going to show you what the deal is
with this, but before we do anything,
what I want you to do is installed
two dependencies with me. Okay. Ready?
So the first dependency we're going
to install is sites on itself.
It's acts just like a
regular python package.
Okay.
Uh, but, uh, so we have po,
we have siphon,
and then we're going to use spacey,
which is spacey is an Nlp Library,
the fastest and LP Python Library that
exists currently that uses carefully
constructed Siphon Constructs for
memory management to allow for rapid,
um, p part of speech
tagging and, um, you know,
tokenization and word two VEC [inaudible]
and all of those little NLP techniques
that we need.
Okay.
So these are the two libraries that we're
going to install and this is going to
take like probably two minutes to run.
So just let's let these dependencies
installed while we talk about, uh,
the rest of this. Okay. So spacey
takes a little time to install.
So as you can see, spacey is installing
right now, by the way, because of Colab,
I just want to, you know, I gave, I
gave Colab a shadow on, on Twitter,
but really amazing tool. No longer
can anybody use the excuse. Well,
it doesn't work for my windows
environment or my whatever environment.
Now you can do it in the browser.
All right, so back to this, right.
So, um, python, it's
great. Like I said, uh,
but when it comes to execution
speed necessarily, it's
not that good necessarily.
Okay, so, right,
so here's a little image we can see of,
of what's happening here.
When we writes out some Siphon code,
it's going to be compiled
by the siphon compiler.
Now this is a specific compiler made to
work with the python compiler is going
to create two. Uh, it's going
to create two different, uh,
files, a c file and N. Dot.
S O file.
And both of them are going to be able
to be launched from a python file later.
Now what is the difference
between C and Python? Now,
not, not everybody knows. See,
not everybody has been able to um,
write spacey.
Spacey is a very cool library.
I really like spacey.
So not everybody's able to has,
has had experience with c.
But what is the real difference
between both of these languages? Well,
there's one, um, besides the memory
management stuff that I talked about,
um, there is one thing that is a
big difference and that is, uh, the,
the idea of strong versus weak typing.
As you can see in this image right here,
right?
So C has strong typing,
meaning the type must be known by the
compiler and Python has week typing.
And this is for,
this is,
this is also for memory management reasons
that it always comes back to memory
when it comes, when it comes to the
sea versus python debate. Uh, but
let's go ahead and write
out a simple example first.
So what I want to start off with in
this example is some basic python. Okay.
Let's see if our dependencies installed.
By the way. See it's still running.
It's gonna take a little a
little while. But um, well, okay.
So while this is, this
is a download, let me,
let me just answer some questions
in the comment section. Someone,
uh,
is very happy that I use spacey.
And why see though?
Well, like I said, Mitch,
mission critical applications need,
uh, the, the maximum speed that we can,
we can,
we can utilize what were the two imports?
The two imports are Siphon and spacey.
Okay.
So Siphon is the set of see extensions
for python that we will use and spacey is
built directly on top of scythe
on. So it's like, it's not,
it's not pure siphon but
it's very close to it.
And it's made specifically for
Siphon.
Which laptop do you have?
I have a Mac book pro
2016 I think or 2017.
I don't like the touch bar
at all. Uh, and in fact, I,
I envy people who don't have a touch bar.
Can you please explain about
both dependencies? Like
I just did, I love, see,
I love C as well. How much of see
should I know? Great question.
So if you're doing anything in
robotics, right? So a mobile robots,
factory, robots, um, robots,
then you're going to need to know some,
see why?
Because when it comes to hardware,
what you're dealing with when it comes
to robotics specifically is a bunch of
integration issues, right? You've got
to get the arm connected to the, uh,
the body connecting to the wheel base,
connected to the other arm or whatever
it is. And all of these are drivers.
Usually they're written in c plus plus
or c. And this can be annoying, right?
It's because we have to integrate all of
these and ideally it was all written in
python, but that's not the
case. So we need to know some,
see if we're going to do
anything in robotics. Meanwhile,
this is still loading.
Have you tried Gpu Laptop?
I have. I have. Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
but you know what, overall I liked
the form factor of the Oh, of Osx.
I liked the fact that I can
use final cut pro and uh,
that's why so c is so much faster.
Yes, it is. I'm just going to,
I'm just going to start typing this
wild while this loads, by the way.
So let's create these rectangles,
right?
So what are we going to do right now
is we're going to create a big bunch of
rectangles, right? In Python,
pure python, no siphon.
And then we're going to count how
many rectangles we have. Okay?
And so this is going to be a speed test.
So let's just do this right now.
So the first thing I'm
going to import is this. Uh,
and this is not going
to require scythe on,
so I can go ahead and just
start coding this right now.
So we want to create a random,
a bunch of randomly size rectangles.
That's why imported this pseudo random
number generator called random. Now,
inside of our rectangle class,
good object oriented programming practice.
We're going to have an
initialization function. This,
this is the initialization
function for the rectangle.
The rectangle is going
to take two parameters.
It's going to be the height and the width.
So I'm going to have the height
and the width, right? So though,
because rectangles can have any different,
the,
the width and height of
rectangles are different.
That's why I have two parameters for
those ELLs. It would not be a rectangle.
Now I'm going to write out the formula
for defining the area of a rectangle.
What is, can anybody tell me the formula
before I type it? It's going to be yes,
it's going to be the weight
or the width times the height.
Very simple, very simple
area formula. Now,
okay, so we have those two
initialization functions. Now we can say,
let's check out these rectangles. It's
let's see what's what's happening here.
So in this we're going to check to see
if it's area is within our thresholds.
So we're going to have
some threshold value. Yes,
this video will be available later on
Youtube and I will answer questions
periodically as I'm coding this.
What we're going to have is a
function that's going to check the,
the um, area of each of the
rectangles that I create.
Now this counter variable in
is going to start at zero.
Now what we're going to say is for every
rectangle that we have in our list of
rectangles,
which is our parameter,
we're going to check,
yeah,
we're going to check if I just
want to make sure this is proper.
Um,
right.
Nope.
Yup.
Good.
Zoom.
I'll zoom in a bit. Let
me zoom in more. Okay.
So for each of the rectangles
that we have, we're going to say,
we're going to check if that,
if the right,
if the area of the rectangle is
greater than our threshold value.
Now if it is greater than our threshold
value, then we're going to say,
let's increment our counter because
that's what we're looking to count.
And then at the end of all of that will
return the number of rectangles that we
have, number of rectangles
like that. Okay.
And I made the screen bigger.
Cool.
Okay.
It could be less than, but let's
just say greater than. Okay.
So now we're going to say, let's, uh,
let's have this main function and we'll
call it slow because we're going to
speed it up in a second.
And we're going to say the number of
rectangles is 1 million rectangles,
1 million. We want a million
of these things, rectangles.
And
we're going to initialize this rectangles.
Object to list that we're going
to input. Yes. Move 37 is free.
That we're going to input into the,
yeah,
a previous function that I just wrote.
Okay.
For every rectangle in the range of
the number of rectangles that we have,
and then,
and
closed that,
and now I can perform the check.
So now I'll perform the check and
I'll say, check those rectangles.
Check every single one that we
have and just see, just see, like,
uh,
I'll call this check reg rectangled pie
or check rectangles
pie now just to see if,
how, how many rectangles we have. And now
we can finally define that's 10 million,
isn't it? 10. Oh, you're right.
That's 10 million rectangles.
That would have been a lot.
Uh, it doesn't matter actually.
They're really very small.
The footprint is small and we can now
print out everything that we have now.
Okay,
now let's see if this compiles.
Good. Now let's time. Oh, let's see if
our dependencies installed. By the way,
are you serious? Oh No. Okay, great.
Great. The dependencies installed.
Yo See us coming. Relax.
One step at a time.
This is a process, my
friends, this is a process.
You can't start running until
you start walking. Okay?
You gotta walk before you crawl.
That's not how it works. Okay?
So let's run this thing. We'll say,
let's run this. We have our function.
Let's run it. Time it.
What do we got here? Okay,
this is creating a bunch of
rectangles and it's okay.
So there are 400 Oh let's see,
there are 403,987 rectangles
that were within our threshold,
okay? And that took a CPU time of
2.23 seconds to do all of this.
Now let's see how much we can
speed this up using Psiphon.
Okay, so now here's how we're going to
use C in the browser. Get ready for this.
By the way,
let me make sure everything's good.
Here's how we're going to use see
in the browser. Okay, so here we go.
I'm going to say low. The extension on
this just told Colab to
load a site on extension.
Now let's do this.
Okay,
so now what we're going to do for this
faster site on implementation is we're
going to say, here, get ready
for this. We're going to
use a siphon flag like this.
That's all we have to do. Now this, this,
this code block is going to use Psiphon,
okay?
So the first Siphon,
a file that I'm going to import,
it's called PSI men and what this is,
and I'm going to use the word [inaudible]
specific keyword seat important.
Instead of just pure import.
Now what this is is it is,
it is a memory management helper for
python specifically poor, the poor object.
We're going to use it to allocate and
we can also use it to deallocate memory.
Now in the case of this program,
we're going to use pool to allocate a
bunch of rectangles. Yes, the scream,
the stream is recorded and you're
going to get to see it later.
Okay?
So that is our first tool.
And then we're going to have
some good old python as well.
For our random number generator,
we can use both sides on and python
in the same code block under um,
what's it called? Magic cell. Uh, magic
sell keyword or something that this, uh,
this thing up here. Okay, so
now let's, let's do this again.
So we're going to create the
statement called see death. Okay,
so what seed def is it to stay?
It's a site on specific statement that's
used to declare, see variables, types,
functions, anything see related,
we can use c deaf for that, right?
So what we can do in c is create a struct.
Our type rectangles.
This is our type and now we
can use pure see variables.
A float for our with a
float for our height. Okay,
so that's our see deaf for our struck.
Now
it's just like Malaak. Exactly.
It's just like Malak. Good question.
Keep them coming. So now let's write
our new check rectangles method.
Okay,
so check rectangles.
cy instead of Pie.
Now what are we going to give this thing?
What are the first parameter is going
to be of course, or a rectangle,
but we're not just going to
give it a plain rectangle.
We're going to give it a pointer.
Hold on. Pointer, pointer, rectangle.
Because,
because what is a point?
Or can anybody tell me
what a point or does
a point or points to a space in memory?
Why?
Why do we use a point or why don't we
just call that object as a whole? Because,
uh,
we can avoid making a duplicate of that
object if we can just point to where it
is in memory.
We don't have to make a duplicate.
That saves a space and
that makes things faster.
So that's where we're going to
use a pointer to, to the memory.
Yes.
You need commas.
Okay.
So I'll call this rectangles
and I'm going to have a number
of those rectangles. Right.
Okay.
And I'm going to have of course,
my threshold.
Yeah.
We want to save memory.
Exactly.
What's one of the core values
that our community has?
Can anybody tell me that's
related to saving? Saving memory,
saving money, saving time,
saving energy. Unnecessary stuff.
What is it? So someone can tell
me, well, like while I typed this,
be frugal by the way. Okay, back to this,
I forgot it for a second. Oh my God.
I've forgotten one of my own core values.
Our own core core value. All right,
so see deaf that, that's that. Okay. So
now we're going to continue. Like I said,
we can you see that for declaring
functions for variables as well.
And so we're going to have
this see variable int that.
We'll use that for.
Okay.
So now we're going to do the same loop
that we did before just like before
except
uh,
s c arrays contained no size.
So no size information that is,
so we need to state it explicitly,
which is what we're doing right here.
Yeah,
you guys are hilarious. By the way. You
guys say the funniest things in the chat.
Java is a robust and secure language.
All caps.
That is what needs to be said.
You know,
like completely random stuff
like that is the greatest man.
You guys are hilarious. Back to this. So
what, what are we going to do here? Well,
we're going to do exactly what we did
before. We're going to take our weights.
We're going to multiply by our height,
and that's not our weight.
I'm to machine learning mode right now.
Our width by our height,
that's going to be greater
than our threshold.
And then we can say increment that
and we'll return the number
number of them. Okay.
Make sure that's all good. It's
all good. Yup. It's all good.
Yep. Now back to our main method. Now
let's do this main rectangle. Don't worry,
we're getting to the machine learning.
We're getting to the machine learning.
I just want to demo some scythe on.
Just just show you the performance gains
that we get from this thing and prove
that we can code,
see inside of this Colab as well,
which I had to get working myself. This,
it took a while, but really it's a,
you know, it's easy. Thank you.
The area of the rectangle is
initialized randomly for all of them.
There are a bunch of them.
It's not just one rectangle.
So how many are we going to have? We're
going to have, like I said before,
a million. Okay. We have
a million rectangles.
We have this threshold value just
like before, it's gonna be 0.25.
Now let's use pool. Get ready for
some python people or some seat.
Now here, here we go with
pool, by the way. Okay,
so the pool object is going to save,
is going to save memory addresses
internally. And so then in the F
it's not like garbage collection is not
happening. It's still happening. Okay?
Garbage collection is still happening.
However,
we can manually allocate and
deallocate memory. In addition to that,
which is going to save us
some runtime resources.
So I'll say
four rectangles.
Typo.
Where? Four rectangles. Uh Huh.
We'll see.
We'll see where the typo is.
So we're going to initialize
our rectangles right now.
This is our list of rectangles and this
bracket is going to typecast r w w the
object that we allocate
here into a rectangle.
So here is us using this pool object has
men to allocate all of these rectangles
just like that in memory.
Now what's the size is going to be,
this is some pure Seaver by the way.
The size is going to be the size of
the rectangle that we just defined.
All. All right Matt, this is
going crazy with Java by the way.
I don't know why you guys are mentioning
Java. This is about c and Python.
So get that job of talking about
here. Yes, Java is lame. I agree.
Java is lame. I'm just going to say
that. All right. Back to this. Okay.
Java. So old John was like computer
science classes in like like 10 years ago.
Um, I know I'm going to get some
hate for that. I don't care. Anyway,
I'm just kind of trolling. No, I mean
it's true. I don't like Java anyway.
I mean there is deep learning for J. I
don't want to get too into this right now.
I'm,
I'm coding something.
This is like an all out war of
programming languages happening. Okay?
So, so let's do this now. Okay.
So we're gonna do the exact
same thing we did before.
So for every rectangle we have,
we're going to initialize book it's WIC
with and its height randomly that and
that's why we imported that random,
uh,
that random important. Okay.
So we'll do that for the width.
We'll do that for the height.
Oh my God. That's hilarious. Okay. So, um,
so now we've randomly allocated all of
these with all of these heights and now
we can use our check rectangles function
that we just defined and give it the
number of rectangles and the
threshold and we're good. Right?
Right, right. Yes. Good.
Print them out. Print them
all out. Okay, everybody good?
Where's the extra parentheses?
Gimme Line numbers people. Okay,
let's see what's going on here.
Is this going to work? Who knows?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
I see,
I see.
Okay, so it's got an error. Okay.
Okay,
Gotcha, Gotcha, Gotcha. Gotcha. This
rectangle opulus. Let's check this out.
Oh yeah. Right. Duh. All
right, let's get back to this
if rectangle. Right? Where's that?
If rectangle
dot w what does it say?
What's the error?
Okay, let's see what,
let's see what I did here
for rectangle.
It's like one of these typing errors.
I'm like doing multiple things
here at once. See that rectangle?
Yup. Yup. I see.
So it's four rectangle in
rectangles and that's how that goes.
I know I should have enabled line
numbers. Oh yeah. How do I do that?
Enabling line numbers.
Four rectangles.
Let's see here.
Okay.
I'm just going to go through this
siphon. All right. You guys are,
you guys are distracting me.
Hold on.
I'm just going to put you in
the corner for a second from,
they've got cy thon imported the pool.
I'm just going to go over,
this could be cause
necessarily. Anyway, we,
we imported the pool for
memory allocation and then
we created our structure.
Our struct are type a rectangle type.
And then we said,
let me just see,
let's just do this.
Okay,
let's just compile that.
Okay.
This proves that we can compile,
see colab.
Okay, so that was the first part. Now
let me do the same thing over here.
I'm just going to break
this up. Break it up. Okay.
There we go.
In valid syntax.
Oh, you know what? It's
gotta to be inside of a,
I've got to have this magic
thing going on. Uh, Sai Thong.
Oh,
okay.
We, okay. We got some, we've
got a lot of NLP NLP to cover.
By the way, I have this code on get hot
by the way, so definitely check it out.
It's the latest repository that I have.
Definitely check it out.
We've got other things to cover here.
These are my comments, by the way.
Some amazing comments. I have to say
myself. What? Wait, we'll wait. Oh, okay.
This one away. Okay, cool. I was, I was
about to say like, wait a second. Okay,
now let's time it.
Let's see the difference in timing.
Main rectangles fast.
Good. Okay. Milliseconds.
842 milliseconds compared
to what it was before.
Yeah. Control ml. Okay, thank you.
2.3 2.23 seconds versus 842 milliseconds.
That is a two x. How many
milliseconds are there in a second?
1,000 how many times
were there 2000 so yeah,
it's like a two x speed up for the
same thing. Okay, so there we go.
Rule number one, do not do a live
demo. See, that's how exactly.
If you, if you can't code it,
sometimes you got a copy paste.
You got to keep going. I'm a human, you
know, so that's how that goes. All right,
so now we've timed it. No. Okay.
So that's it for [inaudible],
straight to machine learning.
Now we've got that out of the way.
So when we're doing natural language
processing, we're dealing with strings,
right?
We're dealing with strengths and see
isn't necessarily all of these like,
um, numerical functions aren't
necessarily made for strings.
But what's so what we need is to kind of
intermediary solution that allows us to
use the fine grain control over memory.
That c allows a,
which allows for a faster
execution environment but
also a high level interface
that lets us deal with strings.
So what spacey is,
is it's this great library. I love this.
Uh, I love this branding by the way.
Industrial Strength, natural language
processing, fastest in the world,
big claim, big, big claim. And look
at this, look at this beautiful,
oh man. As, as a technical writer,
I just, I love their documentation.
Um,
I love their design,
especially at like of the terminal window
and the colors and stuff are very cool
stuff. So when it comes to
natural language processing,
we have to do a bunch of,
um,
preprocessing steps before we feed any
kind of text data in to a deep learning
or machine learning model,
whether it's a neural network or
a support vector machine, right?
This includes tokenization,
part of speech tagging. Part of,
let me slow down part of speech tagging,
dependency parsing,
a named entity recognition.
What is this word? It? Well,
it's a, it's a person. It's,
it's a place, right? So,
so I really think like if we took
this comment section and we just,
I think the birth of all programming
means memes come from the wizards in this
common section. By the
way, like we are the,
we are the source of all
programming means God is html.
Exactly. Exactly. Okay. So
all right, so that spacey,
so let's,
let's code some spacey right over 400
times faster than an t k which I've done
videos on before, which is amazing.
It's a newer, it's a newer lie.
It's newer than El Nltk. NLTK
is pretty old. So we gotta get,
we gotta get with the Times.
And the,
and the coolest part I think is
this idea word vectors, right?
So before we input words into
a machine learning model,
we have to convert them into
vectors. Okay. We have to
convert them into vectors.
And vectors are a representation
that is easily possible by function.
Approximators like neural
networks. So, so what does,
what specifically is spacey doing two
strings? Well, what it's doing is,
what it does is it stores every string
in a single Beta structure called string
store. Okay. This is a, this, this, and
then this is a c, this is a c object.
And then all of these strings are
indexed by a 64 bit sea level hash,
right? So Hash is the same idea
behind bitcoin. You know, this,
this long string of characters like
numbers and numbers and letters.
And what this allows us
to do is very fast lookup,
constant time look up and
constant time a storage, right?
So retrieval and storage are both
constant time, which is awesome.
And this is very fast. But so that's
what it's doing under the hood.
It's converting every string into this,
uh, in this, into the string store object,
uh, it storing it and then it's
you were indexed by this hash.
So whenever we need it, we
can, we can, um, pick it up.
So,
okay.
Uh, yeah, so there's that.
And so there's a bunch of things
that we need to do tagging.
So we're going to do a few
of those examples right now.
And the great thing about spacey is it
integrates with all of these major deep
learning libraries very easily.
There are so many examples on
get hub of this happening, right?
Here's one example by the, here's
the spacey a repository. By the way,
they've got a bunch of great examples.
If we just go under the examples folder,
uh, we've got oh care os nice deep
wanting care, Ross. All right, so what,
let's see what they're doing here.
They're doing an LSTM sentiment
classification model, right?
So they're trying to detect,
you know, what the sentiment
of some words are, right?
This is natural language
processing or a part of it,
okay?
So notice in their
training loop before they,
here's their LSTM model, before
they give, uh, the, the, the Corpus,
the text to the model to train,
they are turning it into a bunch
of vectors. Word vectors, right?
Like I said before, how
are they doing this? Well,
what they imported spacey up there and
then they said spacey don't load English
vectors. So they've got a bunch of
English factors preloaded just like that.
And then we can take this NLP object and
we can say, well, make it into sentences,
get those word embeddings and
then input those to the model.
So this is a preprocessing step.
Works very well with deep learning models.
Let's do a bunch of those
things right now. Okay.
So the first thing we'll do
is we'll set up spacey, right?
So we can say import Spacey
Dot Cli Spacey Dot Cli. Dot.
Download.
We want the English a corpus.
And um,
we'll say load
it right here. Yeah. And it's for English.
All right.
Yeah. Okay, we've got that. And
now we want some test data. Okay.
So let's, let's think of some
test data. Um, I'm going to say,
what do I want there to be
for test data. Um, build it,
train it,
test it.
Makes it be all day.
Train it tests.
It makes it smarter. Better,
faster. No, no, no, no, no,
no. What was it? What was it? Oh my God,
I'm forgetting my own music. Oh my God.
Okay. We got to see this for a second.
Smarter Saroj how does this go?
This was like build a train it test.
It makes it denser or deeper.
Faster or smarter, but, but at
that the, okay. That's what it was.
Makes it denser, deeper, faster,
smarter.
I got to read papers to
try and make me smarter.
I train my models into, cause
my takes longer. Oh man, that's,
that's a sick song by the way. Sometimes
I'm like listening to that. Like,
just like walking, like I'm
listening to my own music. Okay.
We're talking about spacey, not my
smarter Song. All right. Where were we?
All right. Yes, I know Hindi, by the
way. I know Hindi. I know Spanish.
I know [inaudible]. I know a little
bit of Russian. I'm learning Chinese.
I need to learn some Chinese. And uh, yes.
So don't even question what the deal
is, you know, like I know, I know,
I know Hindi. Okay. So,
mmm.
I got to read papers to
try and make me smarter.
I train my models. Okay.
That's the second line.
Okay.
In the cloud now,
because my laptop takes longer,
I parse through data
like a one more line and then we're done.
Okay.
Like,
like a boss now.
Back then mock code was wronger
subscribe if you want to learn.
Now let's spread this AI power. Okay,
so four lines. Do you know English? No,
actually I'm still learning English. I
don't know English. So maybe someday.
I hope. I hope someday I'll
learn how that works. Okay,
so we have our,
um,
we have our test sentence that
will input just like this.
And now we have our parsed data.
Let's see if this works.
Oh, right. Space Spacey.
Breve yet. Breve yet
my friend. I will wrap.
Don't tell me don't wrap because that's
gonna make me wrap even harder. Okay.
That's how this works. You know
what I mean? That's how this works.
Let's see where we are time wise.
Okay.
35 minutes. Good. I'll definitely wrap
now. No, I was going, I'm, I'm Delfin Rob.
All right. Here we go. Space. He's
not defined. I did. Oh, right. See,
I can't even spell my own thing. All
right, here we go. I don't speak Tamil.
Aldo. I should, there's this
hilarious like Tom Hill movie,
which is like all these robots,
like hundreds of them or something
or it's like this. It's hilarious.
Uh, Parse multisense yeah,
I did define it. Oh, right.
Yeah.
You can now load it. Yes.
Okay. There we go. I loaded the
model. Right? So here we go.
Let's do some part of speech tagging.
So what we're gonna do is we're going to
look for the part of speech of each of
these words in my test corpus.
Okay. So I'm going to say,
okay.
Parsed data.
I,
so that's all of those
words that I just defined.
Yeah. I speak, I speak Dutch as well.
Wholehearted. I speak some Dutch.
I mean it's a hard language. I just
spent a year in Amsterdam, by the way.
I spent an entire lifetime in a year.
That was some pretty
mmm.
Incredible stuff.
Don't want to get too reminiscent.
I don't want to reminisce.
Reminisce about things like Tupac.
Okay.
I'm feeling like a joker today on
this live stream, man. Alright,
back to this.
I'll reminisce.
Alright. Part of speech tagging or
was that okay, what are we doing here?
So we're going through each of those
words in the parse data and we're saying
where does it start, where does it
end? And then for each of those words,
we're going to, we're going to tag
it. Okay. So each of those, should I,
I should say tokens,
we're going to say print the the word as
well as it's part of speech and you'll
see exactly what I mean right now.
[inaudible]
break is invalid syntax.
Really?
You Go, you go. No, no, no. Okay.
Well I'd be attending these
conferences. Look after slush. Okay.
Slush in Helsinki. Nothing can
compare. A slush was the most epic.
And I know I'm really promoting slash
by saying this right now and their
applications are gonna go up. But slush
was the most epic, um, conference ever.
I mean, okay. Let me just give
you guys a little secret. Okay.
So like I go to this, okay. There's this
like speaker's dinner. Okay. This too.
There's too much to like talking about
right now. We've got to get the coat on.
Okay.
Close the brackets, right?
That's what it is. Of course,
right?
Yup. Yup. Porkin. Where's Torkan?
Toke and
orth
and then underscore,
get Joe brackets,
right.
Boom.
Oh,
verbs. Nouns, punctuation marks,
build it, train it. Tested.
Makes it denser. The Berg faster. Smarter.
I got to read.
Okay.
So that was one part we can
do more dependency tagging
named entity recognition
where we at time wise, 39 minutes, we
were still good torque and exactly.
That's how we roll torquing.
All right. So, uh, that was
one thing that we could do.
Let's, let's do another thing.
We can do some dependency
tagging. Now. What is this?
I am 27 years old.
Helsinki's in the house. Um,
how to reach you right here. Here I am.
Kim Show means how are you in Gujrati?
I'm good. Uh, that's
some Russian right there.
It says in Sylvia Tura. No, I'm just
kidding. Rap. Got to read them papers.
All right,
so dependency tagging is when we have a
bunch of words that depend on each other.
What specifically do I mean?
Uh,
yeah,
there's a tree of words that depend
on each other. So it's actually,
I should have had a
slide for the dependency.
Tagging on image speaks a thousand words.
There we go.
So it's just like this right submitted.
Who submitted the bill? Well,
bills were submitted by
who? That's the preposition.
What's the object? As senator,
what is his description? Republican
of Kansas, whatever, et cetera. Right?
So it's just like that.
Now let's do this
in our example. Let's, let me, let
me do another wrap line of mine. Uh,
what was my latest rap? Uh, it was
like, this model is taking too long.
I need addenda.
And then it's like
when they update the weights, they
call it, they call it back propagate.
They call it back propagate. Find that
in your dictionary back propagate.
And they want it the waste,
they call it back for per day.
That's what every single section of
these new papers say. That's what,
let's just leave it at that.
Okay? So that's our example.
And now that we have our example,
we can say
put it into our English.
And now for every token that
we have in our parsed example,
now that it's been formatted properly,
let's print out both the original,
um,
tag for it as well as its dependency.
So notice how all of these attributes
of the token keyword is what we're using
here.
Okay,
head. And this is using
scythe on under the hood.
So notice the hell I'm not
specifically typing out to sea,
but it's very close to it.
Okay.
They're not in text form.
They're just somewhere in my head and on
the internet in terms of videos. Okay.
Now. Okay, so for each of those files I
want to show what the tree looks like.
So that's why I'm going to say what's
on the left and then what's on the right
of the tree. Right. So,
okay.
T dot.
Worth for t n token dot.
Rights.
Let's see what happens here.
Good.
When they update the wait, they, okay, so
that's dependency tagging. There we go.
Like I said before and now for the,
okay,
so next time I will do
line numbers. Okay. So
Hola, Como Estas? [inaudible] Raj,
Yo Hablo Espanol. Tambien which
means my name is Raj and yes,
I speak Spanish very well. And I was just
listening to deaths by, oh by the way,
cause I'm going to la in an hour and I
always listened to desk pasito before I
go to La because this is how we
do it down in Puerto Rico. That,
that makes sense. Okay. The thing about
named entity recognition is it. So, um,
it's not as relevant,
but basically it's like
w w it just comes down
to us using this token,
these attributes of the
word token. Right? But, um,
I think that's it for this video.
Yeah, this is a good amount.
This is a good amount of
prostate, but definitely check
out these docs, these doc,
this documentation for spacey.
It's some great stuff. Um,
I want to see more people
using c implementations,
more wizards using both scythe on to
speed up implementation that their models
for data preprocessing,
especially when it comes to NLP.
I will be very impressed by that.
Um,
and you can expect us to go more
low level in the future. And uh,
that's it for this livestream.
Now I'm going to do a rap part.
Let me do a wrap here and then we're done.
We're done.
Someone say a word and then I'm going to
freestyle to that to say a word ideally
about machine learning.
Okay.
Let me just pull up an instrumental,
Julia.
I guess it's going to be,
I try to use NLP.
Don't you see all of these word vectors?
I think it's three down,
man, king woman, Aubrey, where I'm trying
to add these up and subtract. Damn,
don't you care? You can add them.
Multiply it. You can divide.
You can use all of these operations,
man. It's all in your mind.
Think of these words is numbers
that you can add into the track.
Try to think of them as something
more as they go back to bat.
You can line them up,
you can put them in a dictionary,
you can put them in any data
structure. It's history. Yo. Okay.
That's it for this rap Ganz this next
time, but that was my short wrap.
Thank you everybody for coming. I love
you guys and for now I've got to go to la,
so thanks for watching.
All right,
that's it for this stream.